[Música]
en medio oriente Líbano atraviesa por su
peor crisis económica en décadas y sus
ciudadanos ya han comenzado a tomar
medidas extremas para recuperar sus
dólares atrapados en los bancos por eso
la asociación de bancos decidió Cerrar
todas las sucursales a partir de hoy y
Durante los próximos tres días para
hablar del tema nos acompaña Erick bejar
Villegas él es profesor de economía del
tec de Monterrey y decano de ciencias
económicas de la universidad
internacional de Berlín y también está
con nosotros nuestra periodista
especializada en economía Daniela
Blandón les doy la bienvenida a ambos
especialmente a nuestro invitado Eric
Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
nuestros estudios todo empieza o no por
el colapso del sistema bancario en 2021
en Líbano Cómo se llegó a esta crisis
bueno no se tiene que devolver inclusive
hasta los años 70 para ver que el Líbano
ha estado sufriendo por Las Guerras la
guerra civil hasta el 90 y luego la
guerra en el 2006 con is el problema
tiene que ver con una crisis de
endeudamiento es decir que el gobierno
está utilizando el dinero que tiene para
pagar deudas para pagar intereses una
crisis de liquidez y también otro
problema muy grave Es una crisis de
confianza que la población no tiene en
sus gobernantes entonces si yo quiero
tener acceso a los dólares que he
guardado y no me los dan me da pánico
claro y cómo se explica que si esto es
un problema del gobierno ideal y la
deuda del gobierno Entonces cómo llega
también a los bancos y como una persona
llega a la sede de su banco y le dice no
los recursos que usted tenía ahorrados
acá ya no están o peor Aún si tienes por
ejemplo 700 dólares guardados te vamos a
dar 200 Pero eso no quiere decir que el
resto va a estar ahí guardado para ti y
para el futuro sino que esos 200 es todo
lo que hay y todo lo que habrá en el
futuro entonces las personas están
sumamente preocupadas ya ha habido casos
de gente que va con armas de mentira a
asaltar los bancos pero por casos
gravísimos por ejemplo para pagar
tratamientos de Cáncer y así
sucesivamente Y eso también hace digamos
un efecto una bola en todo el país que
de por sí ya ha tenido un desempleo del
48% en el 2018 que tuvo esta crisis
terrible con la explosión del depósito
nitrato de amonio en 2020 donde murieron
más de 200 personas y a eso se suma el
tema también de los refugiados de Siria
es decir las cosas se juntan con la
pandemia también para una situación
grave en el país y sigamos profundizando
este tema que usted menciona y es la
población y los efectos que de esta
crisis económica tienen ellos usted ya
nos contaba algunos datos de por ejemplo
ciudadanos asaltando bancos con armas de
mentiras pero Cómo vive la población
teniendo en cuenta sobre todo que el 80%
de los habitantes están bajo la línea de
pobreza están viviendo muy mal en este
momento porque también cuando uno tiene
una crisis financiera y una crisis
económica una de las variables que
miramos siempre es el desempleo el
desempleo es muy alto y cuando la moneda
se deprecia tanto quiere decir que un
país tan dependiente de las
importaciones va a tener que despedir a
muchas personas por ejemplo los
restaurantes los hoteles Y así
sucesivamente si yo no puedo comprar
insumos porque me cuestan mucho porque
mi moneda no vale nada entonces
obviamente voy a tener que despedir a la
gente en mi empresa
esto es una situación que no es nueva
para el Líbano llevamos ya varios unos
tres años en los que se ha empeorado
porque ha empeorado tienen estos últimos
tres años y qué se ve entonces de cara
al futuro también hay un acuerdo
pendiente con el fondo monetario
internacional por ejemplo era una bomba
de tiempo desde el 2016 de hecho los
bancos empezaron a traer las remesas y
atraer también ahorro desde el exterior
pero también desde el interior diciendo
que iban a pagar intereses muy altos y
el gobierno también se permitió subirse
los salarios justo antes de las
elecciones del 2018 Entonces al prometer
tanto la gente metió los dólares en las
cuentas y después de eso con el 2019
cuando las empresas salieron a buscar
dólares para poder importar porque
recordemos que el Líbano lo que exporta
son joyas tiene que importar todo
petróleo y tiene que importar medicinas
Y de qué importar textiles entonces
mientras que exporta 3.000 millones de
dólares importa 20 mil millones es decir
que están dependiendo fuertemente los
mercados internacionales y esa bomba de
tiempo se da porque en el 2019 la
escasez de los dólares explota al no
tener dólares Entonces no se puede
importar Y como el estado estaba
endeudado con los bancos que le prestado
esos dólares de la gente que tuvo la
confianza hay colapsa Todo es una crisis
de confianza y cómo esta falta de
dólares esta crisis de confianza y esta
crisis económica del Líbano está
afectando a medio oriente El problema es
que estamos hablando de una región muy
inestable ya sabemos que el problema es
Siria que ha tenido efectos en no solo
en esta región sino también en Europa
por el tema de los refugiados lleva que
hay una migración masiva el Líbano ha
tenido alrededor de un millón doscientos
hay otras cifras que hablan de un millón
y medio de refugiados que han llegado
también países como Turquía lo han
vivido y el problema es que ahora con
algunos movimientos militares que hace
por ejemplo Turquía hacia Armenia por
ejemplo y también en la frontera con
Siria hay una preocupación muy grande en
general recordemos que hay otro digamos
otra teoría que nos dice o más bien
digamos una hipótesis muy clara que el
Líbano es una especie de
satélite de la guerra que quiere hacer
Arabia Saudita contra Irán e Irán contra
Arabia saudí es decir es una especie de
guerra satélite que sufren los
habitantes del Líbano y que
desestabiliza toda la región hay un tema
también en la región que es un Común
denominador y es la devaluación de la
moneda no solamente en Líbano sino en
sus vecinos también si nos vamos hasta
Libia hay muchos países en donde la
moneda ya no está costando casi nada
frente al Dólar como Pues sortear esta
situación o sea Cuáles son las
soluciones que hay a la vista para estos
países que están pasando la tan mal
económicamente pues las soluciones de
siempre tienen que ver con austeridad en
el gasto Pero obviamente eso implica
también que hay menos dinero circulando
Y que por lo tanto la crisis económica
se puede recrudecer pero parte del
compromiso por lo menos lo que se está
hablando con la Unión Europea y con el
fondo monetario internacional es también
un control sobre el problema de la
corrupción y también algunas variables
específicas Para no ir a poner impuestos
en donde no debe ser recordemos los
impuestos más graves que puso el Líbano
y que llevó a estas a esta pequeña
revolución de octubre fue el de WhatsApp
Es decir le impusieron un impuesto suena
un poco repetitivo Pero imaginemos esto
a las llamadas de WhatsApp de 20
centavos diarios Entonces si este tipo
de cosas no se cambian y la austeridad
no parte más bienes de reducir el gasto
por ejemplo para pagar menos intereses
Entonces no se va a poder hacer nada
ahora Francia por ejemplo es un país que
está también muy involucrado en este
tema de la no solo de la reconstrucción
como ha sido un tema histórico del
Líbano sino también de la estabilización
de las finanzas si un país no tiene un
sistema bancario estable como lo tuvo el
Líbano En el 2007 y 2008 de hecho fue
uno de los pocos países que creció en su
bolsa durante la crisis mundial
difícilmente el país va a poder salir de
este de este problema Entonces se tiene
que estabilizar el sector financiero y
obviamente cerrarlo tres días No
necesariamente es una señal muy
alentadora pero es necesaria para que no
haya una corrida sobre los bancos que lo
que le pasó a Argentina del 2001 lo que
pasó en Japón en 1900 en los en los 20 y
lo que también siempre se ha temido en
pues prácticamente en todas las
economías del mundo usted nos hablaba de
un posible recrudecimiento a un peor de
la economía libanesa y de la economía de
la región que se puede esperar entonces
en Líbano especialmente luego de este
cierre de tres días bueno Esto sí todo
es posible realmente uno como economista
puede anticiparse de pronto algunas
cosas pero no predecirlas yo veo un
riesgo y es que aparezcan también
digamos síntomas de más violencia
recordemos que ahí está hezbolá de por
medio que tiene una enemistad de hace
mucho tiempo con Israel que es el país
vecino que sí es próspero económicamente
y también pensemos que otra cosa que el
Líbano puede digamos en lo que puede
caer es en un cambio sobre ese acuerdo
en 1989 que es cuando la secta
religiosas se Entre ella repartirse el
poder si se llega a romper esto también
podemos estar hablando inclusive de
conflictos con fundamentos religioso que
serían sumamente graves esperemos que
eso no pase y que se logre estabilizar
los mercados financieros Bueno aquí hay
un componente muy importante que es el
fondo monetario internacional y voy a
volver sobre él porque ha aparecido como
el rescatista de todos estos países no
solamente en Líbano también en sri lanka
en algunos países de América Latina pero
el fondo monetario internacional es
bastante impopular porque llega a exigir
unas condiciones que los países no
tienen porque no hablamos también un
poco de eso porque es tan impopular el
fondo monetario internacional y Qué
ventajas o desventajas tiene que entre a
rescatar a los países Bueno en ese club
de los impopulares sí siempre aparece el
Banco Mundial el fondo monetario
internacional y en algunos casos uno
entiende también por qué cuando uno va a
prestar plata pone condiciones no y esa
plata claramente tiene que ver con la
idea de poder recuperarla en algún
momento entonces tiene que haber
credibilidad el fondo monetario y el
Banco Mundial han exigido normalmente es
sanear las finanzas quiere decir reducir
el gasto público o hacer digamos que el
gasto público fluya hacia algo más
productivo el problema también y eso se
vio en la crisis con Grecia en 2012 más
o menos y por eso había críticas contra
el fondo monetario internacional o
contra la famosa troica porque también
había otros actores es que también hay
que pagar los intereses y esos intereses
son muy costosos Grecia en esa época
estaba pagando más o menos el 90% de lo
que él entraba a sus acreedores entonces
claramente por eso no es popular el
fondo monetario internacional Pero por
otro lado si ese dinero no fluye la
economía y hay una vamos a ponerlo así
como una especie de resequedad
financiera si no hay dinero no hay
transaccionalidad es decir no se pueden
hacer transacciones no se pueden pagar
cosas eso es peor Entonces es impopular
pero para evitar el golpe puede ser
necesario